[Musik]
das wird die spannendste und die
wichtigste bundestagswahl für sie und
ihren alltag und wir machen jetzt den
check was kommt er wirklich auf sie zu
wie teuer wird es für sie nach der wahl
also tanken fliegen steuern abgaben all
das klären wir jetzt denn anders als die
anderen hier machen wir keine
sommerpause 80 tage lang sondern die
ganzen sommer hindurch stellen wir die
richtigen fragen ohne gebühren jetzt
live bei bild und damit herzlich
willkommen livebild wie teuer wird es
nach der wahl das diskutieren wir jetzt
mit diesen gästen nämlich mit anna
lührmann der grünen bundestagskandidat
in die schon mal im bundestag war damals
als 19-jährige rein gewählt in dem
bundestag die bilder mit gerd schröder
und joschka fischer 2002 bis 29 war sie
im parlament danach hat sie eine lange
parlamentspause gemacht und will sich
jetzt für die grünen zurück kämpfen in
den bundestag der csu-generalsekretär
markus blume ist bei uns der ja
eigentlich wollte dass markus söder
rechts im bild der kanzlerkandidat der
union wird und jetzt muss oder darf er
wahlkampf machen für den herrn links im
bild für armin laschet der spd
generalsekretärs klingbeil ist bei uns
natürlich will dass er hier das olaf
scholz der neue bundeskanzler wird und
volker wissing ist bei uns
fdp-generalsekretär der für christian
lindner seinen chef den
bundestagswahlkampf organisiert außerdem
bei uns dick neubauer er ist
bürgermeister der kleinen gemeinde
augustusburg das ist in mittelsachsen
hier sehen sie schöne bilder aus der
luft von augustusburg und dirk neubauer
macht sich sorgen um das funktionieren
unserer demokratie in diesem
bundestagswahlkampf in allen schönen
guten abend nach diesem wochenende an
dem grünen parteitag war auf denen wir
alle geguckt haben und vor allen dingen
gegen star jahr
wer aber von vier babys diesen
unmittelbar nach ihrer rede als sie das
podest erleichtert verlässt und dann
haben sie es gehört
irgendwas nicht so richtig gut fand frau
lührmann was könnte ihre chefin die
kanzlerkandidatin der grünen scheiße
gefunden haben naja also erst einmal
muss man sagen dass das dass ein wort
ist was wir hier alle glaube ich glaube
ich schon einmal verwendet haben
annalena baerbock ist das ist ja nicht
wahr
der berg ist ja als perfektionist in
bekannter kann sicherlich mal was
gegeben haben was wir nicht so gut
gefallen hat insgesamt ist der parteitag
aber super gelaufen
die partei hat sich geschlossen hinter
anna lena gestellt er zeigt nicht mehr
die szene frau lehmann zeigt nicht diese
szene unter welchem druck sie da stand
dass man dann auch vergisst dass das
mikrofon noch offen ist man geht zu
erleichtert runter irgendwas fand man
nicht so gut zeigt nicht diese szene
unter welchem druck die
kanzlerkandidaten steht nach dem dilemma
um ihren lebenslauf nachdem corona bonus
na ja wir sind alle menschen und ich
finde es auch ganz gut wenn wir der
politik dass ab und zu mal zeigen und
natürlich sie hatte eine sehr große
verantwortung die hoffnung von millionen
von deutschen nun auf ihr nämlich von
all denen die veränderungen wollen die
nicht wollen dass mit dem status quo
weitergeht
die wollen das wir uns vorbereiten auch
die klimakrise dass wir etwas tun damit
die erderwärmung nicht so rapide
ausfällt wie sie wie sie sonst ausfallen
würde
die wollen dass unsere wirtschaft sich
vorbereitet vorbereitet wird auf diesen
einstieg in das klimaneutrale zeitalter
und dafür ist sie die kandidatinnen und
das ist natürlich eine große
verantwortung
herr blume ich habe schon gesagt alles
schaut so sehr auf annalena baerbock die
grüne kanzlerkandidatin in diesen tagen
in diesen wochen die grünen polarisieren
unheimlich starkes scheint im wahlkampf
darum zu gehen entweder die grünen
wählen oder die grünen unbedingt
verhindern warum ist das so warum
polarisieren die grünen so stark
ich glaube das müssen sie die grünen
fragen ich teile auch nicht die ansicht
dass die menschen in deutschland jetzt
auch die grünen gewartet haben dass die
ins kanzleramt einziehen
ich nehme eigentlich inzwischen ein
anderes grundgefühl war dass die
menschen eigentlich sich gerade in
diesen zeiten von unsicherheit wünschen
deutschland weiterhin stabil regiert
wird und dass jetzt da nicht große
experimente antreten
und wenn ich auf dem parteitag der
grünen blicke dann glaube ich hat sich
nochmal das bestätigt was man die
letzten drei vier wochen schon gemerkt
hat da gibt es doch ziemlich risse in
der grünen fassade man kann fast sagen
der lack ist ab offensichtlich schweiß
der wille zur macht im moment die grünen
zusammen sie wollen unbedingt regieren
aber das was da programmatisch auch
präsentiert ist das ist doch etwas was
viele menschen in deutschland
verunsichert darüber streiten wir gleich
noch ohren detail ich habe gerade gesagt
die grünen polarisieren im moment
unheimlich stark ich will ihnen eine
zeitungsanzeige zeigen eine große
beziehungsweise ein plakat das stammt
von der initiative neue soziale
marktwirtschaft ist am freitag zum
beispiel gedruckt worden von der faz da
sehen sie die grüne kanzlerkandidatin
unter der überschrift wir brauchen keine
staatsreligion in der fotomontage im
grünen gewand das soll ein bisschen an
moses erinnern mit den zehn geboten es
gibt die zwei tafeln in der hand und da
hat die initiative neue soziale
marktwirtschaft jetzt nicht zehn gebote
sondern zehn verbote darauf gedruckt die
sie den grünen beziehungsweise ihrer
kanzlerkandidaten in den mund gelegt hat
bzw auf die tafel gedruckt hat du da ist
kein verbrenner autofahren du darfst
nicht fliegen du darfst nicht im freien
handel teilnehmen
du darfst nicht schöner wohnen und und
und wie gesagt dass den grünen in den
mund gelegt frau lührmann muss man sich
als grüne muss man sich als
kanzlerkandidatin sowas gefallen lassen
also für mich zeigt diese anzeige dass
auch offenbar einige in deutschland die
millionenschwere lobby interessen hinter
sich haben angst davor haben dass grüne
ins kanzleramt einziehen und das da
gegenwind kommt das war aber zu erwarten
das heißt ja auch nicht umsonst
wahlkampf ich will noch mal auf den
ersten punkt hier in dieser
anzeige eingehen da steht ja was über
den verbrenner motor ist es so ich habe
jetzt die letzten sieben jahre in
schweden gearbeitet ich kenne ich sehr
gut aus auch in europa und international
und international ist klar dass der
verbrenner motor ein auslaufmodell ist
großbritannien zum beispiel will 2030
aus dem verbrenner motor aussteigen das
heißt keine neuen verbrenner zu lassen
und das heißt wenn wir unsere deutschen
autors weiterverkaufen wollen
international
dann müssen wir umsteigen auf
elektromobilität und wir grüne wollen
dafür die rahmenbedingungen setzen und
zwar so dass jeder sich das auch leisten
kann
herr wissing haben sie über das plakat
gelacht oder den kopf geschüttelt
ich habe darüber geschmunzelt aber ich
kann nachvollziehen dass die thesen der
grünen die menschen provozieren
hier steht ja ganz offensichtlich ein
linksruck an
die grünen bereiten ein linksruck vor
frau werbung hat sich ja auch nicht auf
die frage ein gelassen ob sie denn
bereit es sich von der linken zur
kanzlerin wählen zu lassen
und das spricht ja bände und dass dann
eine initiative neue soziale
marktwirtschaft die sich um die
marktwirtschaft bemüht auch provoziert
und da richtig kräftig einsteigt das ist
für mich nachvollziehbar
und natürlich wird in solchen bei
solchen kampagnen auch manchmal etwas
überzogen aber ich laufe immer zählen
ist das überzogen ist das überzogen oder
nicht es ist zugespitzt aber es ist auch
richtig dass im wahlkampf gewesen
die thesen spitz gestellt werden die
grünen vermeiden ja über ihre inhalte zu
reden jeden haben machen wir schon heute
abend machen wir schon heute abend
erklingen bei früher hat sich die
initiative neue soziale marktwirtschaft
janin an der spd-abgeordnete und da auch
millionen damals rein gesteckt sind sie
ein bisschen enttäuscht dass sie jetzt
nicht mehr taugen für die großen plakate
ich wäre sie leider nicht erklingen weil
das reparieren war schnell ziehen einmal
den ton bei ihnen drauf liegt an ihnen
oder an uns okay wollen noch mal
probieren erklingen bei sind sie
enttäuscht dass die initiative sich
nicht mehr an ihnen arbeitet nicht mehr
an der spd
lasst uns zusammen schrauben an dem
tunnel frau löhrmann ich will noch mal
bei auf sie zu sprechen kommen sie haben
gesagt lobbyarbeit will die industrie
sie verhindern
die gründe das geht nicht das geht
sicherlich nicht für die gesamte
industrie wir haben viel unterstützung
bekommen zum beispiel hat auch auf
unserem parteitag der ehemalige siemens
vorstand gesprochen und ich glaube die
klugen menschen in der industrie aber
wen meinen sie sie sagen jetzt gehen sie
nicht mal einen aber wie in meinen sie
mit der millionenschweren lobbyarbeit
ganz kurz den gedanken seine firma city
wie die klugen in der industrie wissen
dass sie eine chance haben in der
zukunft wenn sie sich jetzt umstellen
auf klimaneutralität es ist ja auch so
zum beispiel so dass in der
finanzindustrie an den börsen wird
verstärkt darauf geachtet ob die
unternehmen nachhaltig sind das heißt da
gibt es sowieso auch den markt anreiz
und wir als politik müssen dafür die
richtigen rahmenbedingungen setzen
wenn ich damit meine sind das sind
natürlich die finanziers die hinter
dieser initiative neue soziale
marktwirtschaft stehen das sind zum teil
noch die verbände in der tat aber ich
glaube die einzelunternehmen sind da
viel weiter ich war da jetzt auch in
meinem wahlkreis unterwegs hat
verschiedene kleine mittelständische
unternehmen besucht und denen ist allen
klar dass sie mehr machen müssen für
nachhaltigkeit die haben ja auch kinder
die wollen dass ihre es ihren kindern
später mal gut geht wir wollen dass die
kinder auch in freiheit leben können
dass sie sich wirtschaftlich entfalten
können und den weg müssen wir jetzt eben
gemeinsam gehen indem wir unsere
marktwirtschaft umbauen zu einer sozial
ökologischen marktwirtschaft kriegen
bald zurück mit dem ton jetzt auch noch
mal die frage an sie sind sie enttäuscht
dass die spd nicht mehr trifft das die
nicht mehr taugt für so eine kampagne
millionenschwer von der initiative neue
soziale marktwirtschaft so ich hoffe sie
haben mich jetzt hier war ja wohl ist
ich hoffe es geht wunder also wir kennen
diese initiative in der tat auch weil
sie häufig auf uns abzielt wir haben das
zuletzt erlebt als es um rente gegen
olaf scholz das abgekriegt und das muss
man schon klar benennen das sind
finanziert dahinter die wollen nicht
dass es soziale verbesserungen gibt die
wollen nicht dass politik für rentner
für arbeitnehmer politik des sozialen
miteinanders gemacht wird ich glaube
aber auch und da stimme ich anna lehmann
zu es gibt mittlerweile ganz andere
diesem land es gibt mehr berliner die
sagen ach sonst lass uns in den sozialen
zusammenhalt in diesem land finanzieren
es gibt unternehmer nicht sagen meinen
sie entschuldigen institutionen
ermöglichen ganz kurz finanziers einer
solchen kampagne das kostja ordentlich
schotter die erstmal zu entwerfen dann
auch zu drucken und ist natürlich ganz
klare motivation die grünen maximal zu
provozieren und zu verhindern
wer steckt sie haben jetzt beide in den
verdacht geäussert klingen weil wer
steckt hinter solcher kampagne wer sind
diese finanziert das gras ist die
initiative wehrt hat genau mit dabei ist
da gehe ich nicht hinterher in der tat
wir haben wahlkampf da gibt es heftige
auseinandersetzung aber man muss dann
noch klar benennen worum es geht und
noch mal da sind menschen die haben kein
interesse dass es soziale verbesserungen
gibt die hand kein interesse daran dass
der staat anders funktioniert das muss
man hinnehmen in wahlkampfzeiten man
kann das aber auch klar und deutlich
benennen aber ich lese jetzt nicht wer
da alles mitglied ist und wer alles zu
geld reinsteckt stehen die grünen in
ihren augen herr blume für die soziale
marktwirtschaft
ich glaube das problem ist doch
offensichtlich ein anderes dass es
inzwischen viele menschen gibt die in
deutschland doch sorge haben sorge haben
dass die grünen das wahrmachen was auch
vor allem an gerade noch mal gesagt hat
nämlich deutschland umzubauen und zwar
sehr fundamental und vor was ich nur
warnen kann ist dass die politik glaubt
es besser zu wissen
es ist ja gerade formuliert werden also
formuliert worden dass wir jetzt der
deutschen autoindustrie sagen müssen was
sie zu tun hat ich sehe dass die
deutsche industrie sehr genau weiß was
auch den internationalen absatzmärkten
gefragt ist und selbstverständlich mit
hochdruck in neue formen der mobilität
investiert wird aber dass man jetzt
hergeht und hier verordnet ideologisch
verordnet was zu welchem zeitpunkt
passiert ausstieg des verbrechers zum
jahr 2030 glaube ich stehe jetzt im
grünen wahlprogramm manche wollten sie
sogar noch schneller haben
da zeigt sich eigentlich etwas anderes
dass die grünen seit jahren auf einem
feldzug sind gegen auto mobilität
generell gegen mobilität und dieses
momentum konnten sie nie ablegen
wir diskutieren heute darüber und vor
allen dingen über die frage wie teuer
wird es für sie
nach der wahl diskutieren sie doch mit
uns twittern sie mit uns unter dem
hashtag die richtigen fragen können sich
an dieser sendung mit beteiligungen sich
miteinander austauschen über die
kandidaten über unsere gesprächspartner
mitdiskutanten austauschen und wir
wollen jetzt weiter sprechen über das
tanken und über die frage ob dieser
wahlkampf auch an der tankstelle mit
entschieden wird herr wissing wird das
so sein wird der tanker sozusagen wird
der mit entscheiden über den ausgang
dieser bundestagswahl
ja was die grünen mit dem benzinpreis
vorhaben ist total unfair gegenüber den
menschen im ländlichen raum
sie wollen die mobilität verteuern aber
was sie nicht sagen ist dass die
menschen ja im ländlichen raum gar keine
möglichkeit haben vom auto auf den öpnv
umzusteigen
das heißt der effekt für den klimaschutz
ist gleich null
exakt null die leute werden einfach nur
tiefer in die tasche greifen müssen wenn
sie zur arbeit oder zu verwandten fahren
die sie pflegen müssen
und das finde ich ehrlich gesagt eine 30
kite schalten wir einmal schalten wir
einmal wissen kurz dorthin wo auch die
bundestagswahl entschieden wird nämlich
an eine tankstelle am sonntagabend nach
lorch ganz in den südwesten der republik
zu sebastian uhr an schönen guten abend
eu land finden sie tanken gerade einmal
voll sie pendeln nämlich ständig müssen
berufs aus beruflichen gründen von lorch
nach untertürkheim noch ein stück weiter
pendeln das sind wie viel kilometer
jeden tag für sie jeden tag 96 km ganz
grob und deshalb bis zu sechs tage die
woche größtenteils sechs tage 96
kilometer insgesamt hin und zurück
pendelt jeden tag was macht das ungefähr
im jahr für sie an spritkosten aus genau
ist der sprit kosten pro jahr zirka 2300
euro aktuell beim aktuellen preis sogar
2300 euro
2350 euro die ich brauche nur reine
arbeitszeit
die fahrt zur arbeit ohne private
fahrten noch sie sind dreifacher
familienvater haben sie einmal
ausgerechnet was das für sie und ihre
familie bedeuten würde wenn es noch mal
rauf geht mit dem spritpreis um ja 15 16
cent pro liter
also es werden circa also reine
fahrtzeit zur arbeit also was ungefähr
20.000 kilometer im jahr sind das wären
ungefähr 300 euro mehr plus noch einmal
10.000 kilometer die privatfahrer urlaub
weil mit drei kindern kann man nur wohin
fliegen das geht also nur mit dem auto
irgendwo hinfahren wir haben ein hund
und dadurch ist halt noch mal 10.000 km
36.000 kilometer sind dann so ungefähr
450 euro mehr
die im jahr dafür ausgeben müsste 450
euro ist eine stange geld jetzt sagt man
immer so schnell das kann man sich nicht
leisten möglicherweise können sie sich
leisten wenn sie an anderer stelle dann
sparen würden was würde dann wegfallen
für sie also leisten sag ich mal werde
ich mir müssen weil ich muss ja auf
arbeit fahren weil als alleinverdiener
ist es schwierig wenn ich sage ich fahre
ich mir auch arbeit
dann haben wir noch weniger geld aber
wird dann halt ein familienausflügen
scheitern wo man halt sagt man geht im
freizeitpark oder schwimmbad wo man halt
einfach ein grenzen muss oder man muss
halt einen urlaub verkürzen dass man
sagt man kann über das lange wochenende
gehen statt eine woche wo muss das geld
dann wieder rein kommen weil ich muss ja
schon im urlaub dann meistens auch noch
hinfahren das ist ja im prinzip die zeit
sozusagen zweimal also ohne urlaub
machen muss trotzdem noch in fahren weil
man sie kennen solche rechnungen
natürlich was sagen sie aber ganz
konkret herne hula hula und was wäre für
ihn eine lösung wird er einfach damit
leben müssen dass es deutlich teurer
wird und der 350 400 450 euro mehr im
jahr zahlen muss für den sprit nein also
herr roland ihnen kann ich ganz konkret
sagen wir haben vor eine energie geld
einzuführen das soll pro kopf ausgezahlt
werden
1 75 euro pro kopf sie haben gesagt sind
eine dreiköpfige familie ich nehme mal
an dass er noch eine partnerin partner
dabei ist dann werden fünf personen dh
sie würden
im jahr um ein betrag von von knapp 500
euro entlastet werden
das heißt zu sagen unter dem strich wird
die mehrbelastung durch durch diesen
anstieg hier für sie nicht ausfallen
dass das wird vor allen dingen für die
menschen stark ausfallen die singles
sind die sozusagen in einer für einer
familie wohnen und die darüber hinaus
noch vielleicht in einem großen haus
holen und dergleichen deswegen das ist
ja auch der unterschied sozusagen
zwischen unserer klimaschutzpolitik und
dem was die koalition gerade gemacht hat
wir haben ganz klar ein konzept dafür
wie wir das sozial gerecht an die
menschen zurückgeben wollen nämlich
direkt mit einem energie geld und auch
mit einer senkung der erneuerbaren
energien umlage am strompreis das heißt
unter dem strich hätten sie da jetzt
ungefähr das gleiche in der tasche heißt
der uhland noch mal an sie zurück würden
sich darauf verlassen was vor allem an
sagt also der sprit würde erst mal
teurer sie drücken das erst mal ab aber
bekommst dann sozusagen linke tasche
rechte tasche über die grünen wieder
zurück über dieses energie geld würden
sich darauf verlassen
das problem ist dass in letzter zeit
eigentlich nie so war dass man irgendwas
zurück bekommen wir vorher was bezahlt
hat ist schwierige wahrheit immer immer
vorkasse gehen und dann am ende vom
monat oder ende vom jahr ist dann
trotzdem wieder weniger war jetzt schon
oft genug der fall also darauf verlassen
würde ich mich jetzt nicht unbedingt
danke für den moment eu-land diese
rechnung auf jeden fall heute abend auch
falls so spät ist und weil wir wissen
dass sonntagabend richtung montagmorgen
die spritpreise meistens eher wieder
anziehen geht heute einmal auf uns herr
neubauer aus augustusburg in sachsen
warum ist der spritpreis wir merken das
ja auch jetzt hier egal ob nord süd ost
west so emotional so ein zentrales thema
für die menschen also bei uns kann ich
es ganz konkret sagen wir sind ländliche
raum werden sehr wenig verkehrsangebot
die menschen sind extrem an gewesen ob
die individuelle mobilität also spricht
auch der auto- und all die lösung die
diskutiert werden sind unglaublich
schlecht kommuniziert also auch das also
ich beschäftige mich qua amt ein
bisschen intensiver damit und stelle
fest dass die grünen vorschlagen kann
ich nachvollziehen aber es ist
wahnsinnig schlecht kommuniziert bei
dieser ganze politik tatsächlich die
ehrung nicht mehr hat und wir müssen das
mit den leuten verhandeln wenn wir ein
vernünftiges zu erreichen wollen müssen
wir die leute überzeugen und überzeugen
heißt das so mit ihnen in die diskussion
gehen und sie verstehen und ihnen
erklären was wir mit ihnen vorhaben das
ist ganz wichtig sonst werden wir diese
aufgaben nicht schaffen wichtiger punkt
erneuerbarer blume jetzt schimpfen sie
so massiv auf die grünen aber wurden ja
das benzin auch teurer machen wird es am
ende bei ihnen auch über zwei euro gehen
oder können sie eine garantie heute
abend abgeben dass das mit ihnen nicht
passieren wird der literpreis zwei euro
ich denke in der politik ist
verlässlichkeit ein ganz neues und
wichtiges gut genau wir wollen das klima
schützen und dazu gehört natürlich dass
wir fossile energieträger zurückdrängen
beim heizen und natürlich auch bei der
mobilität aber das muss mit augenmaß
geschehen und es muss immer auch die
frage des sozialen ausgleichs oder
betroffenheit gestellt werden und ich
stelle fest hat es gerade mal
überschlagen was man gerade vorgerechnet
hat also bei fünf personen komme ich auf
375 euro und das sind die kosten
währungen durch heizung und anderes ja
noch gar nicht dabei also fakt ist für
die grünen ist das was jetzt hier im
raum steht an 16 cent preissteigerung
quasi die untergrenze das haben ja auch
die beratungen beim parteitag der grünen
gezeigt
für uns in der koalition ist dass die
obergrenze die überhaupt nur denkbar ist
und vor allem auf einem anderen
zeitlichen pfad dass die frage der
mobilität keine konkrete fragen der
mobilität einer ganz kurzer das
beschlagen der mobilität keine frage des
luxus wird weil sie haben gesagt sie
haben ihre antwort eingeleitet mit dem
hinweis wie wichtig verlässlichkeit in
der politik ist sie hatte sie gefragt
nach zwei euro pro liter benzin können
sie eine garantie abgeben dass das mit
ihnen nicht passiert also zwei euro
liter benzin kann ich mir nicht
vorstellen das ist außerhalb des preis
korridors denen die große koalition für
den co2 preis beschlossen hat allerdings
das muss man natürlich dazu sagen
die große unbekannte ist auch die
entwicklung des rohölpreises generell
auch die die politiker zunächst mal
keinen einfluss ich frage das deswegen
weil der unionsfraktionsvorsitzende sich
dazu aktuell ja auch geäußert hat bei
den kollegen vom morgenmagazin hör mal
kurz rein in den ton benzin wird teurer
jetzt ein bisschen in der zweiten hälfte
dieses jahrzehnt ist wird es richtig
teuer
und das ist auch der plan dass wir den
menschen sagen benzin wird teurer aber
ihr müsst nicht sofort eure autos
verkaufen
das ist total großzügig gewesen dass wir
nicht sofort unsere autos verkaufen
müssen herr blume das klingt genauso wie
die grünen es wird teurer der brinkhaus
sagt auch naja stellt euch mal
ordentlich auf was ein ihr müsst nicht
sofort euer auto verkaufen aber wird
schon dicke kommen also die
argumentation hat mich ehrlicherweise
auch nicht total überzeugt ja benzin
wird teurer das liegt darin dass der co2
preis steigt auch steigen muss aber auf
der anderen seite müssen wir eben
schauen uns das ist wollen ja schon
gesagt worden dass wir nicht klimaschutz
zu lasten des ländlichen raums und der
pendler organisieren deswegen sind wir
als csu dafür müssen wir als union dafür
auch die pendlerpauschale weiter zu
erhöhen
denn es hilft ja nichts ein energie geld
über alle zu verteilen sondern wir
müssen schauen dass die entlastungen bei
denen ankommen die berufsbedingt auf
mobilität auf individuelle mobilität
angewiesen sind
hecklingen weil egal wie man zu hauen
alle so drauf auf die grünen aber in
wahrheit wird doch der spritpreis bei
ihnen aufsteigen oder können sie wollen
sie garantieren aktuell dass der
spritpreis bei ihnen nicht über die zwei
euro geht also markus blume hat das
gerade angesprochen wir haben in der
koalition verabredet dass der co2 preis
kommt dass es noch richtig wir wollen
das klima schützen und da ist der co2
preis ein wichtiges instrument aber ich
betone jedoch nur ein richtiges
instrument und es gibt den verabredeten
ausbau fahrt und der sorgt dafür dass
der spritpreis nicht über zwei euro
liegen wird was die politik angeht
sonstige faktoren ist gerade drüber
geredet worden politik ist ja nicht das
einzige was den spritpreis beeinflusst
und das was jetzt gerade passiert das
will ich aber deutlich sagen ist dass
die grünen mit ihren forderungen den
menschen hier bei mir im ländlichen raum
angst machen weil einfach nur den
benzinpreis zu erhöhen und zu sagen und
dann guckt wir damit klar kommt das wird
auch den klima nichts nützen also wir
müssen sie alternativen bauen wir müssen
die alten schon augenbrauen sagen die
grünen die noch gar nicht es ist doch es
ist absurd diese diese debatte ist doch
wirklich absurd und ich bin wirklich
kein bilder und ich bin mit vielen nicht
einverstanden aber machen wir uns doch
endlich mal ehrlich dieses dieses die
bei uns und wir waren es interessiert
niemanden
ihr braucht man ja mit zukunft wir haben
genau und die haben wir verabredet in
der koalition und ich halte auch nach
wie vor das für richtig wir erhöhen den
co2 preis wir setzen auf den co2 preis
aber beschaffen
die umstiegs nur bereit indem wir
erstmal alternativen für die menschen im
ländlichen raum wirtschaft aber richtig
die finanziell endlich ganz neu bauen
noch ein bisschen besser verstehen mit
seinem einwurf eben sie habe gerade
geschimpft wir müssen diese diskussionen
die gehen am thema vorbei weil sie
glauben dass alle menschen wissen dass
der sprit teurer wird das alles sowieso
davon ausgehen und man irgendwie
wahrnimmt dass dann noch so ein
politischer streit existiert aber alle
eigentlichen hinterköpfen genau diesen
plan haben weil sie es wissen dass es
sein muss ich denke dass das jeden klaus
ich vermisse ich vermisste das group die
groß angelegte lösung ich vermisse die
große investition in die alternative
mobilitätskonzepte
das kann ich bei uns nicht erkennen und
das wäre eine tatsächliche antwort auf
die ganze geschichte
die leute wissen dass klimawandel mit
einschnitt verbunden sein wird man muss
es ihnen erklären und man darf doch
nicht drumrum reden und nichts
schönreden oder verschieben oder auf
irgendjemanden zeigen da jetzt endlich
mal den finger in die wunde legt sondern
wir brauchen lösungen das heißt daher
das was er sagt ist doch genau das
richtige die alternativen schaffen wir
haben jetzt in der koalition dem ausbau
omv versechsfacht wir sorgen erst mal
dafür dass es überhaupt diese diese
möglichkeit gibt ladeinfrastruktur
elektromobilität damit das kein thema
nur der menschen in den großstädten ist
sondern auch im ländlichen raum stand
sie haben halt sehr sehen am knoten bald
sogar sehr viele jahre müssen wir müssen
die umstiegs wirklichkeit schaffen sonst
erschreckend wie die menschen und
verlieren sie beim gemeinsamen ziel des
klimaschutzes aber haben sie in
augustusburg ganz kurz der check die
möglichkeit dort sich ganz wunderbar mit
bussen und bahnen zu bewegen
also werden auch buslinien die nicht
fahren wenn schulferien sind bei der
schülerverkehr mittlerweile den öpnv
querfinanziert der phantoms auch mal 14
tage gar nicht wir haben ein stadtnetz
wir haben das jetzt 90 mal selber prüfen
das mit dem energieversorger gemeinsam
das gar nicht in der lage wäre
entsprechend elektromobilität zu
schaffen wir müssen die ganze stadt
umgraben
also haben riesen aufgaben und ich
wundere mich echt dass hier enteilt
weise partei die schon seit zehn jahren
20 jahren regieren jetzt anfangen auf
den letzten drücker sozusagen zu lasten
der leute jetzt der gas zu geben und
dann soll man doch wen ist das ehrlich
sein sondern jawoll
das vergeigt aber jetzt ist das machen
wir müssen unseren planeten retten und
ich glaube dass es jedem klar enke
tauglichkeit nur politik ist ein
riesenthema
das beschäftigt die leute wahnsinnig
aber lasst uns das ehrlich gemeinsam
machen und nicht die leute nicht mehr
hin verstehe er wissen herr neubauer
sagt alle wissen dass der spritpreis
steigen wird redet doch nicht darum geht
es doch einfach zu und stellt uns halt
den bus vor die haustür
also zunächst einmal muss der spritpreis
nicht steigen
das ist ja nicht bin ich mich gesetzt ja
also dass der spritpreis ist ja im
überwiegend von staatlichen kosten
getrieben und nicht von einem marktpreis
getrieben aber jetzt reden wir mal über
den frauen reden wir mal die realität
also der ausbau des öpnv in der fläche
in großen flächenländern ist ja
kurzfristig gar nicht denkbar
wenn wir heute eine schiene reaktivieren
wollen haben wir ja übrigens auch dank
der grünen heute planungs regelungen die
sowas ja erst in jahrzehnten möglich
machen
der ausbau des schienennetzes wenn sie
heute eine planung anfangen brauchen sie
vor dem jahr 2050 nicht damit zu rechnen
dass in irgendeiner weise irgendeine an
den finger rühren kauft das ist ja in
deutschland so ich kann mich erinnern an
die jamaika verhandlungen 2017 jede fast
jeder versuch irgendwas zu ändern
präventionsregeln verbandsklagerecht
einschränken die grünen haben immer nein
gesagt
und deswegen ist es doch aberwitzig sich
hinzustellen als grüne parteien zu sagen
wir sind für den kräftigen ausbau des
öpnv in der fläche die ganzen planungs
regeln planungs vereinfachung das ist
doch alles an den grünen gescheitert im
bundesrat oder auch bei verhandlungen
weil man das hat doch keinen sinn mit
dem kopf zu nicken
sie kommen und alles verhindert ich saß
mit dem herrn hofreiter zusammen
zu jeder frage der planungs
beschleunigung gab es immer das gleiche
jetzt auch nach vorne und jetzt lassen
sie uns einmal wissen lassen sie uns
einmal konkret machen planungs
beschleunigung und so weiter einmal ganz
weit in
die in den rückspiegel geguckt gerade
wir haben ja gerade ganz konkrete nicht
wir haben gerade ganz konkrete beispiele
ja gehört zb von herrn roland und auch
von herr neubauer die sagen halt ja
irgendwie wird der spritpreis ja
offenbar steigen das kostet ziemlich
viel geld her uhr land hat uns das sogar
vorgerechnet frau löhrmann
und jetzt sagt er der hat die aber gar
keine alternativen das heißt was machen
sie damit der urahn die wahl hätte mit
dem auto zu fahren oder mit bus und bahn
also erstens möchte ich hier nochmal
sagen wir grünen letzte mal geguckt habe
waren die letzten 16 jahre nicht in der
regierung als ich ja sozusagen genau
deswegen übrigens gar nichts zu tun
ich hab gar nicht nur weil er wichtige
sagt zurück gucken gucken wir noch nicht
zurück gucken sie doch fauna und sagen
sie herr nur land wieder zur arbeit
kommen mit bus und bahn mit mit großem
vergnügen also erstens muss es darum
gehen die mobilitätskonzepte so
auszubauen dass sie halt auch wirklich
überall funktionieren das kann zum teil
eine reaktivierte bahnstrecke sein das
kann zum teil können busse seien das
müssen aber vor allen dingen auch neue
innovative konzepte seien also da gibt
es das stichwort mobility on demand wir
haben ja mittlerweile alle in die
smartphones dass wir dann ist wirklich
hinbekommen sozusagen innovativ uns
zusammenzutun für für carsharing für
fahrgemeinschaften und dergleichen und
schlussendlich und das gehört zur
wahrheit auch dazu und das haben wir
grünen mittlerweile auch sehr klar
ausgesprochen
im ländlichen raum wird die
elektromobilität die individuelle
elektromobilität eine sehr große rolle
spielen und deshalb starten wir zum
beispiel vor unserem wahlprogramm ein
klimagerechtigkeit fonds aufzulegen wo
vor allem menschen die
durchschnittsverdiener sind oder nicht
so viel verdienen noch deutlicher
unterstützt werden
beim umstieg auf die elektromobilität
und natürlich muss es auch eine
bundesaufgabe sein und da hat die
bundesregierung wirklich gepennt in den
letzten jahren die zapfsäulen die ganze
infrastruktur dahin auch da dafür
auszubauen und deswegen herr wissing ist
das eine öffentliche aufgabe für
infrastruktur zu sorgen für straßen für
bahn und eben auch für ein netz von
elektromobilität das ist eine
öffentliche aufgabe neubauer sie
schütteln den kopf
also ich hab schon mal gesagt ist es
vielleicht untergegangen aber ich werde
bei den fakten wir haben unser stadt
netzwerk prüfen lassen wenn bei uns wenn
bei uns nur zehn prozent der bisher an
fahrten dem fahrzeuge auf
elektromobilität umgestellt werden
müssten könnten sie nicht leiden weil
das das stadt stromnetz gar nicht
hergibt das ist eine riesenbaustelle
wir haben zwei lade positionen in der
stadt das ist alles ganz wunderbar das
war doch alles gefördert ich kann auch
meine private blogs zu hause mehr
fördern lassen
nützt aber gar nichts wenn das ganze
dann irgendwie zwölf stunden dauert bis
mir ein auto geladen ist das ist doch
realitätsfremd das den leuten zu sagen
wo sind denn die wo sind die wirklich
durch sprüche im öpnv und das ist glaube
ich relativ einfach zu organisieren und
wenn es wirklich tatsächlich erst noch
mal die wiesel busse sind von mir
wenigstens welche wenigstens welche die
farben auch wenn schulferien das problem
ist dass das konkret dass sie ist genau
richtig gesagt wir streiten schon so
lange über den öffentlichen nahverkehr
das im grunde niemand mehr glaubt dass
es sich wesentlich verbessert ganz kurze
um das aktionen schlussfrage in dieser
runde frau lührmann würden sie denn zwei
euro pro liter in kauf nehmen also preis
hängt sehr stark auch von von
marktfaktoren ja oder nein ja oder nein
würden sie das in kauf nehmen
darauf möchte jetzt hier nicht alles
jeder möchte ich gerne zuhören wissen
auch noch einen satz sagen sie als fdp
schlagen ja vor dass der co2 preis am
markt test warum wollen sie sich nicht
darauf
warum wollen sie sich nicht darauf
einlassen frau löhrmann das verstehe er
verstehe nicht das wissen wir doch alle
dass der prinz schon von sehr vielen
faktoren ab vor allen dingen von steuern
vor allem von den steuern und abgaben
grünen jetzt glaube ich hier bei dem
thema wirklich nicht nicht vorwerfen
nicht konkret genug zu sein gucken sie
sich meine debatte der letzten wochen an
die große koalition hat eine erhöhung
des co2 preises aber schloss aber die
frage
20-25 auf 55 euro pro tonne
wir sagen wir wollen das leicht
vorziehen und auf 60 euro pro tonne
gehen
der unterschied für den co2 preis wenn
man dann nur das macht was die große
koalition schon beschlossen hat dann die
sind wir bei 15 cent pro liter
bisher mein tag dieselbe frage gleich
auch
die kollektion die grünen vorschlag
haben ein land vorbei 16 cent und die
koalition stellt sich jetzt hin und sagt
ja wir wollen den co2 preis erhöhen mit
steigenden spritpreisen haben wir nichts
zu tun das ist doch wie wenn man sagt ja
dass mehr machen wir teurer aber mit
steigenden brötchenpreise haben wir
nichts zu tun
genau deshalb haben sie auch was mit
steigenden spritpreisen zu tun wenn sie
16 cent drauf schlagen wollen deswegen
habe meine frage ob sie zwei euro in
kauf nehmen wollen können wir einfach
sagen nie wäre mir zu viel oder jahr
nehme ich in kauf zu not weil wir
natürlich irgendwie die energie
finanzieren müssen und den klimaschutz
vor allen dingen finanzieren müssen also
eigentlich ganz einfach gewesen herr
wissen wie sieht's mit ihnen aus was
wäre für sie eine rote linie
möglicherweise nach der wahl wo sie
sagen würden das geht nicht also wenn
die grünen oder auch wenn die wir haben
herrn brinkhaus gehört wenn die cdu
damit um die ecke kommt nicht mit der
fdp
ja ich habe überhaupt kein verständnis
dafür den menschen das leben im alltag
teurer zu machen ich weiß auch nicht wie
man mit sowas menschen begeistern soll
das leben im ländlichen raum ist in
vielerlei hinsicht anstrengend genug und
dann zu sagen wir legen da jetzt noch
mal wir haben inzwischen der benzinpreis
ist ja von man sagt das sei ein
marktpreis ich weiß gar nicht wie sie
darauf darauf kommt wir haben wir haben
inzwischen zwei preis am markt
festgelegt und lediglich 63 prozent
steuern und abgaben auf den benzinpreis
von 63 prozent
da ist die realität und das will sie das
thema was beschlossen ist mit den 15
cent würden sie das nach der wahl zurück
finde es generell nicht für richtig dass
man staatlich preise festsetzt ich bin
ein anhänger der sozialen
marktwirtschaft in der sozialen
marktwirtschaft werden preise nicht vom
staat festgesetzt aber es ist silas
wieder ende dran sind
im markt wird macht und deswegen halte
ich das nicht für richtig
wir hoffen wieder rückabwickeln wir
haben einen anderen weg vorgeschlagen
wir wollen dass wir die co2 emissionen
regulieren das weiß ich deswegen die
frage würden sie das wieder
rückabwickeln würden sie das wieder
ändern dass unser ziel ist dass das zu
machen ja weil wir der meinung sind dass
wir nicht in der der sozialen
marktwirtschaft staatspreise festsetzen
sollen ich bin also erschüttert über
er wisse aber er ist das ist auch nicht
ehrlich sagen dass wir wissen natürlich
auch nicht ehrlich denn der aktuelle der
aktuelle klimaschutz pfad und gerade
auch die frage wie die co2 preise
steigen ist ein ergebnis des
vermittlungsausschusses war ein
aufwendiges verfahren
es gab zunächst ein vorschlag der
bundesregierung und dann ging das ganze
in den vermittlungsausschuss und wenn
ich nicht völlig falsch informiert bin
waren autoritär regierten länder
natürlich am ende mit dabei und haben
das gemeinsam beschlossen
aber der punkt ist doch ein ganz anderes
vorhin schon groß aber das ganz cool ich
das ist ja schon interessant das ist
schon interessanter blume weil sie im
guten punkt gemacht haben ob das stimmt
sie sagen dass es nicht ehrlicher
wissing sagen sie es ehrlich sie haben
das mit beschlossen hinter
verschlossenen türen sagen jetzt bin ich
haben uns dafür wir glauben dass sag's
ihnen auch ganz ehrlich halte es auch
nicht für richtig
also ich bin der meinung dass in einer
sozialen marktwirtschaft preise nicht
staatlich fest aber sie haben es mit
beschlossen wie er blume sagt eines habe
ich nicht mit beschlossen
die fdp hat mit beschlossen hat sie auch
nicht die fdp hatten anderen vorschlag
gemacht nämlich die co2 emissionen menge
zu regulieren wir aber die länder an den
sie beteiligt sind also sie regieren
doch in deutschland das lasse ich mir
nicht unterschieden das ist ihr modell
herr blume und ich finde es auch für die
csu ein starkes stück dass sie auf eine
staatliche preisfestsetzung gehen und
nicht auf marktpreise was können sie
nicht anderen anheften dass sich auch
versprochen koalition gewesen nicht der
vorschlag der der der fdp wir haben ein
ganz anderes konzept genau alles haben
ja offenbar hinter den kulissen das
mitgetragen wir wollen einmal sprechen
wir waren gerade ich habe es auch nicht
hinter den kulissen aber er weiß ich
wollte eigentlich noch ganz andere weiß
ich wollte etwas ganz anderes sagen
der punkt ist weil es folgen auch um den
herrn ungarn ging ich will wir wollen
dass der mann auch in zu lang beim
autofahren kann es auch ein ganz klarer
punkt weil es wird regionen in
deutschland geben dass es illusorisch zu
vermuten dass da morgen dann der
öffentliche nahverkehr so ausgebaut ist
bienen urbanen räumen wo viele der
grünen-anhänger leben wir wollen den
öffentlichen nahverkehr günstiger machen
die koalition hat übrigens bahnfahren
stichwort mehrwöchigen künstlern gehört
wir haben in bayern 163 bayern 365 euro
ticket wir müssen in die infrastruktur
investieren
wirklich die einladung an die grünen auf
ihre blockade von wichtigen
schienenverkehrs projekt x aufzugeben
aber nochmal ich will dass in
deutschland der durchschnittsbürger auch
in zukunft mit dem auto fahren kann ja
der umschlagen wenn es keine anderes nur
mehr bezahlen noch einen punkt den
freiheit den handybauer gerade gemacht
hat und den ich kurz mit herrn klingen
bei besprechen möchte denn der punkt war
ja von der neubau auch bei einem so
großen unternehmen wie dem klimaschutz
da müssen wir die leute mitnehmen da
müssen wir ganz anders mit die
entsprechen dann müssen wir den kann
darf man keine angst machen
die schweiz hat gerade über wichtige
klimaschutz punkte abstimmen lassen und
da gab es eine vernichtende niederlage
für zb den co2 preis für sprit für flüge
und so weiter und so fort wie würde das
ausgehen da klingen weil wenn man in
deutschland abstimmen würde
ich bin fest davon überzeugt dass die
mehrheit der menschen will dass wir
wollen klimaschutz vorankommen und die
dringlichkeit steht ja auch hier in
dieser runde überhaupt nicht infrage
sondern es geht um die frage des ließ
und noch mal da haben wir jetzt einen
weg festgelegt der einen moderaten co2
anstieg hat aber der die menschen
mitnimmt gebe markus blume recht ist
muss darum gehen dass die menschen im
ländlichen raum weiter pendeln können in
die städte und dass das kein luxusgut
ist und es muss um alternativen gehen
und das finde ich das finde ich ja weise
muss die eigentlich wichtige debatte ich
merke dass bei mir hier im ländlichen
raum die frage der mobilität wie komme
ich von a nach b das ist mittlerweile
das wichtigste thema es hat nicht mehr
jeder ein auto oder der arzt ist nicht
mehr vor ort oder die einkaufs
gelegenheit ist nicht mehr da und dann
muss man jetzt mit neuen konzepten ob
das bürgerbusse sind in den glücklichen
vater rief mit einbezogen werden ob das
sammeltaxi sind ob das andere möglich
und da habe ich manchmal das gefühl dass
diejenigen die in den großen städten in
den metropolen leben dass die gar nicht
verstehen die lebensrealitäten vor ort
sind und das ist ein wahnsinnig
wichtiger punkt wir streiten uns jetzt
an der halben stunde über den
benzinpreis wichtige debatte aber die
frage wie sieht neue mobilität aus in
diesem land wie können wir sicherstellen
dass die menschen von a nach b kommen
diese debatte kommt in der politik für
zu kurz ja die sie natürlich kann sich
bestimmt haben in den letzten jahren
herr neubau kommt zu ihm weil der
klingbeil hat gerade einen satz gesagt
da ist sich die runde ja auch einig in
der schweiz war sich die runde auch
einig da waren alle parteien für diesen
co2 preis ausser der svp und am ende hat
die mehrheit der schweizer aber
dagegen gestimmt deswegen noch mal die
frage sehe das in deutschland genau so
aus die runde hier ist sich einig frau
lührmann mit der klingbeil wissing mit
herrn blume und am ende sitzt die
mehrheit der deutschen aber beim
klimaschutz anders weil die sagen nö
also diese art von veränderung wenn mich
das was kostet das mache ich nicht
die frage ist doch ich sage nochmal die
frage ist wie sind alternativen
aufgezeigt wie offen ist eine debatte
auch für neue ansätze wie die klassische
kommunikation und ich habe auch eine
frage von welchen durchschnittsmenschen
gehen wir denn bitte aus ich hab nur bei
mir in der stadt die sollen im öpnv auf
eine einfache fahrt 42 fürs einkaufen
bezahlt ich habe nur rentner ehepaar die
sehe ich als sie sehe ich wirklich
mehrfach in der woche hand in hand mit
mein kaufs trolley quer durch die ganze
stadt laufen weil die natürlich
gemeinsam einkaufen wollen aber weil die
nicht 240 pro nase bieten und 42 pro
nase zurückbezahlt werden dann dürfen
wir bitte auch nicht übersehen in
ostdeutschland verdienen wir immer noch
400 euro im schnitt weniger als im
besten fall nation durchschnittsbürger
gehen wir bei diesen rechnungen aus das
sind die richtigen fragen und noch mal
ich denke tatsächlich lassen für busse
form wenn schulferien sind schließen wir
die lücken machen wir vernünftige takt
geworden dass auch ja das kostet auch
geld aber ich glaube wir müssen erst als
einer tiefen schafften bevor wir läuten
dann sozusagen ihr bisheriges
beschreiben als rechtlich wirklich also
hätten herr neubauer wenn ich ihnen
zuhöre die 16 euro oder auch 15 15 cent
in augustusburg keine mehrheit
sicherlich wieder einmal ganz kurz mit
ihnen einmal machen per handzeichen wenn
es geht wer von ihnen das auto ist ja
auch ein statussymbol wer von ihnen
fährt gerne schnell auf der autobahn
immerhin herr wissing irgendwie nicht
und frau
man mag es auch nicht so sind sie für
ein tempolimit mit den grünen von dem
wir das ja wissen zu haben
nein auf keinen fall der wissing
herr neubauer würde das befürworten
ich bin dabei der blume armin laschet
hat heute ausgeschlossen
wir haben in deutschland die meisten
straßen ohnehin geschwindigkeits
reguliert und dieses thema tempolimit
ist ein fetisch die die grünen seit
vielen jahren vor sich her tragen
ich glaube es gibt viele gute gründe
gegen ein generelles tempolimit weil wir
bereits heute alle möglichkeiten haben
verkehrs angepasst die geschwindigkeit
einfach mehr baustellen mach ich halt
geht vor völlig außer frage
einfach mehr baustellen machen frau
lehmann ist das für sie ein ganz
wichtiger punkt mit blick auf die
mögliche zeit nach der wahl ist das was
wofür sie richtig kämpfen würden als
grüne die mehrheit der deutschen ist ja
mittlerweile für ein tempolimit selbst
die mehrheit der adac-mitglieder ist für
ein tempolimit weil einfach ja auch alle
in europa unterwegs sind und sehen dass
das in anderen europäischen ländern
standard ist ich habe die letzten sieben
jahre in schweden gelebt da ist
tempolimit standard und ich muss sagen
es ist etwas angenehmer auf den
autobahnen auf den überlandstraßen in
schweden zu fahren weil nicht so gefasst
wird es ist sicherer die zahl der
verkehrstoten ist niedriger das heißt
das ist eine maßnahme die ist gut für
die gesundheit also sozusagen für den
lebensschutz aber eben auch für für das
klima weil eben hier schneller gefahren
wird umso mehr co2 wird sei ausgestoßen
und deswegen glaube ich ist das eine
eine sehr sinnvolle maßnahme
und da klingbeil sie würden sich dass
sie haben gerade ganz ehrlich gesagt sie
fahren ganz gerne schnell würden sie
sich gerne von den grünen verbieten
lassen
also ich fahre in der tat sehr gerne
schnell nur die wahrheit ist das geht
gar nicht mehr wenn ich auf den
autobahnen unterwegs bin gibt es da
schon überall tempobegrenzung oder man
steht im stau und insofern ist das gar
nicht möglich und ganz ehrlich verweise
ich finde diese debatte ist mit abstand
nicht die wichtigste für die
bundestagswahl wir müssen reden über
rente wir müssen über höhere löhne reden
wir müssen darüber reden wie wir
deutschland stark halten auch im
internationalen wettbewerb aber dass es
gibt doch gute argumente mittlerweile
fürs tempo 130 in der verkehrssicherheit
auch in der frage klimaschutz
die argumentation von herrn laschet
heute in der bams die war wirklich
abenteuerlich zu sagen na ja wenn
elektromobils auto hat der kann noch
schneller fahren also das können sich
gerade wirklich nur die gutverdiener in
diesem land reichen das heißt der lasche
zahl die die kohle haben die können
schnell fahren und die anderen sollen
langsam fahren also das ist wirklich
abenteuerlich aber ich sage es gibt
wichtigere diskussion als das tempolimit
und ich hoffe das ist bei der bundestags
da stimmt aber es gibt schon auch es ist
eine sehr emotionale diskussionen wie
auch die übers reisen zum beispiel
wärmer wochenende gesehen welch riesige
jets im moment nach mallorca fliegen
nämlich mit diesem jumbo weil die leute
die deutschen einfach hungrig sind nach
der korona zeit aufs reisen die wollen
halt fliegen die wollen nicht weniger
fliegen frau lührmann die wollen im
moment mehr fliegen ja und jeder soll
das auch selber so machen ja dass ich
das gerne möchte also ich wäre es
niemandem vorschreiben ob er nach
mallorca fliegt oder aber sie wollen
etwas weniger gezwungen wird sie wollen
etwas weniger geflogen wird
das ist das ist mir egal ja es geht
darum es geht um die rahmenbedingungen
die wir setzen momentan ist es ja so
dass kerosin als
einzige art oder als einziger sozusagen
antriebsstoff in deutschland von der
steuer ausgenommen wird also wir zahlen
steuern für benzin wir zahlen steuern
auf den strom bezahlen steuern wenn wir
bahn fahren aber es bezahlen eben keine
steuern fürs fliegen und ja es gibt
deswegen finde ich auch schon alleine
aus dem thema soziale gerechtigkeit
heraus finde ich das was vor über wir
reden müssen sozusagen kerosin aus
dieser subvention herauszunehmen und
wenn es auch mal umgucken wer ist es
denn der am meisten fliegt am meisten
fliegen die gutverdiener im land das
heißt das ist ein maßnahmen gebunden
die bundestagsabgeordnete ich das sagen
darf die natur ist voll über man im
moment ja nicht muss man fairerweise
sagen aber er blumen hat diese weise
noch hinten noch mal nachgelegt die
grünen sind als dienstreisen besonders
häufig geflogen eine zeitlang in der
bundestagsfraktion wir sind sie nach
göteborg zu ihrem job immer gekommen bin
ich in der tat meistens mit dem zug
gefahren
das weise ich habe eine wunderschöne
rote entdeckt man kann von von frankfurt
aus mit dem zug nach kiel fahren und
dann auf die fähre gehen und dann ist da
am nächsten morgen in göteburg am anfang
habe ich das ein bisschen abgeschreckt
weil es dauert 24 stunden aber dann habe
ich entdeckt dass diese art des reisens
auch ein enormer zugewinn an
lebensqualität ist weil man eben da da
an bord des schiffes ist also von daher
ich glaube wir müssen sozusagen uns in
dieser ganzen debatte mal ein bisschen
frei machen von von der vorstellung dass
das alles irgendwie mit mit großen
einschränkungen verbunden ist im
gegenteil wenn man mal sachen anders
macht es werden sie im alltag aussehen
dann kann davon auch kann dadurch auch
viel besser wäre wenn man fahrrad fährt
freut sich auch ihr arzt oder ihre
ärztin ja also von daher will eine woche
die woche die es braucht um dann
irgendwie mit dem auto und der fähre
nach mallorca zu fahren die ist noch
nicht klar sagen sie jetzt man kann dann
einmal auf mallorca urlaub vielleicht
verzichten aber wir merken doch gerade
jetzt vor allen dingen nach corona wie
hungrig die menschen auf den mallorca
urlaub sind herr wissing dh iss fliegen
im moment eben nicht zu billig sondern
die menschen suchen genau danach die
wollen im moment auch wieder reihenweise
massenweise zu zehntausenden am mallorca
fliegen also eher weise das problem ist
doch nicht das fliegen
billig ist wir können noch nicht
ernsthaft uns als politiker hinstellen
kann sagen wir möchten gerne dass die
dinge für die bürgerinnen und bürger
teurer werden das doch absurd
das problem des fliegens ist doch nur
die co2-emission und deswegen müssen wir
eine lösung finden wie wir co2 neutral
fliegen können das geht beispielsweise
mit synthetischen kraftstoffen
aber ich finde dass man sich hinstellt
und sagt ich finde das ist für die
bürgerinnen und bürger zu billig es muss
teurer werden das finde ich einen
merkwürdigen politischen ansatz ich
freue mich wenn die menschen mobil sind
und dafür nicht tief in die tasche
greifen können wie sähe das ist da
klingelt es kriegen so billig deswegen
sollten wir nicht irgendwie uns
politisch darauf verständigen dass die
dinge für die menschen teurer werden
müssen das wird nämlich dann am ende so
seien nicht so wie frau lührmann
verspricht dass jeder sich das dann für
mehr geld leisten kann und die reichen
nicht
das werden dann wenige menschen sein die
sich das teure fliegen noch leisten
können und die mehrzahl der bevölkerung
eben nicht das ist doch die soziale
schieflage die hand legen apropos
soziale schieflage ist fliegen zu billig
muss es teurer werden
also man kann überhaupt nicht pauschal
sagen dass es zu billig ist und ich
halte auch eine forderung dass man sagt
es muss teurer werden für falsch die
leute freuen sich jetzt dass sie alle im
urlaub können und das sei ihm gegönnt
und das sollen sie auch machen aber es
gibt natürlich probleme und da muss man
genau hinschauen wenn ich sehe dass das
manche flügel billiger sind als
eigentlich die flughafensteuern sind
dann ist das ein problem und das hat
olaf scholz neulich adressiert als er
gesagt hat nein flug sollte schon 50
euro kosten und dann glaube ich aber
dass vor allem dinge dadurch geregelt
werden dass alternativen auch
attraktiver werden und klar das gilt
jetzt nicht für mallorca aber ich nenne
mal nur das beispiel berlin münchen da
ist die strecke erneuert worden dies
massiv schneller geworden und ich kenne
ganz viele die seitdem sagen ich nehme
lieber diese zugstrecke als den flug wo
man ungefähr gleich lang unterwegs ist
und es war richtig dass wir in der
koalition jetzt auch die mehrwertsteuer
gesenkt haben auch zug fahren damit das
günstiger wird also alternativen
schaffen und ich glaube dann steigen
viele auch um herr neubau würde gehören
in dieser runde auch von ihnen immer
wieder alternativen alternativen wir
suchen nach veränderung und so weiter
jetzt ist die feststellung aber von
vielen im moment erst recht nach dieser
corona krise wo man wohl das leben von
vielen so durcheinander gewirbelt wurde
man möchte jetzt gerade keine
veränderung man möchte dass alles so
bleibt man möchte
ja im besten fall sein altes leben
endlich wieder zurück die normalität
zurück man will sich jetzt nicht nächste
krise klimaschutz krise wieder
veränderung wird so weiter ist das so
bei ihnen ja ich stelle fest dass man
leuten schon ganz gut darüber reden
können wir selber machen dass unser
stadt werben soll das gesetz format
august ruck 2050 vor der pandemie ins
leben gerufen
das werden wir jetzt auch künftig wieder
aufnehmen jetzt im juli wird es
weitergehen da kommen leute freiwillig
und reden darüber wie werden wir
nachhaltig die können wir wie können wir
uns mit unserer natur aus süden also das
bewegt die menschen fallen sich heraus
ich hatte aber gerne sagt mal was
differenzierendes beibringen als erstes
hat meine frage noch niemand beantwortet
welche durchschnittsbürger denn für
diese ganzen kalkulationen genommen wird
aber schwamm drüber das bin ich
inzwischen gewöhnt aber beim fliegen
tatsächlich muss man doch die frage
stellen sind es innerdeutsche flüge ich
bin früher beruflich sehr viel
innerdeutsch geflogen von dresden nach
frankfurt es macht überhaupt ehrlich
gesagt überhaupt keinen sinn
und hier wirklich die alternativen zu
entwickeln und dann geht es und das ist
beispielsweise dass der stadt wir kennen
jetzt immer noch nicht angebunden jetzt
ist eine schande dass man da nicht
vernünftig mit der bahn fahren kann wenn
ich wenn ich hier von erfurt aus 222
nach berlin fahre fahrrad ece sprinter
für nicht ganz 50 euro in unter zwei
stunden also das ist eine alternative
damit kann man umgehen dann lasse ich
mein auto stehen obwohl ich das wirklich
sehr mag
aber wir müssen die wege schaffen und
das haben wir über jahre und jahrzehnte
leider nicht gemacht und jetzt jetzt
drängt die zeit und jetzt müssen sie ja
wirklich kluge vorschläge machen und
verhalten müssen wir ehrlich mit den
leuten sagen das was ich heute abend
hier wieder höre dass das übliche ihr
habt ihr wart doch und der hat noch
heimlich zugestimmt das interessiert
doch niemanden
es ist das hier doch die band mehr die
leute wollen lösungen die sie verstehen
wenn die menschen das habe ich gerade
mal kurz gesagt ferlemann in diesem jahr
eben gar keine veränderungen wollen wenn
die veränderung ist müde sind nach
diesem corona ja dann hätten sie mit den
grünen problem es ist doch so wenn wir
uns auf die krise die jetzt auf uns
zukommt nämlich die klimakrise wenn wir
uns da jetzt nicht darauf einstellen
wenn wir jetzt nicht alles tun um
die ersterwähnung erwärmung in einem
erträglichen maße zu haben dann wird es
richtig teuer für uns und dann wird die
krise richtig richtig da sein das habe
ich das habe ich verstanden dass cages
prävention die frage ist ob wie weit sie
dabei den menschen in diesem jahr
wirklich durchdringen können denn die
haben eine tiefe corona krise gerade
durch gemacht und die haben sie bzw
die haben den staat so kennen gelernt
dass sehr viele probleme nicht gelöst
hat vor allen dingen im homeschooling
und so weiter vor allen dingen beim
impfen und jetzt sagen sie denen jetzt
kommen sie mit der nächsten krise um die
ecke und sagen wir müssen uns gemeinsam
darauf einstellen vielleicht wollen die
sich mit ihnen gar nicht drauf
einstellen gerade mal gucken sie mal die
krise habe ich mir ja nicht auskennt hat
das habe ich nicht gesagt
das ist ja allgemein bekannt dass wissen
ja alle dass das dass wir das problem
haben der menschgemachten erderwärmung
und dass wir da jetzt handeln müssten
weil sonst sehr teuer wird und weil
sonst das hat das
bundesverfassungsgericht auch gerade
nochmal gesagt die freiheit der jungen
und der künftige generationen krass
eingeschränkt wird so und ich glaube in
der kroner krise haben wir alle gesehen
dass wir als staat eben nicht gut
vorbereitet sind auf solche
ausnahmesituationen die digitalisierung
das ist ja so ein beispiel ich habe in
der pandemie sehr viel von deutschland
ausgearbeitet in einem internationalen
team in schweden
und ich sage ihnen eins wenn da die bei
der video konferenz die verbindung man
nicht geklappt hat dann war das immer
bei den deutschen ja so und das ist doch
kein licht das wir hier in deutschland
nicht an der weltklasse sind was
digitalisierung angeht das internet
angeht das heißt das zu sagen es ist
klar geworden dass wir nicht genug
machen in der prävention dass wir nicht
genug machen im infrastrukturausbau wir
haben marode schulen
wir haben marode bahnhöfe bahnstrecken
wir müssen also wirklich jetzt darauf
den turbo drücken im infrastrukturausbau
wir schlagen dafür ein investitionsfonds
von 15 jahre haben wir fast das ganze
wahlprogramm schon durch das haben sie
super gemacht dass gerade beschlossen
wurde frau lehmann sei mal dahin gefragt
einmal eine schnelle runde durch
erklingen ball sind die chancen von frau
werber kanzler kann kanzlerin zu werden
an diesem wochenende durch diesen
grünen-parteitag gestiegen
ich glaube nicht also es gab ganz hohe
erwartungen an ihrer rede und die hat
sie nicht erfüllt also einen plan zu
haben wo es hingehen soll und diese
ganzen schönen worte mit neuer polit
das reicht nicht schnelle runde sollte
das ja sein herr blume gestiegen oder
nicht gestiegen
also viele haben zwischen große zweifel
an alina baerbock interessanterweise
sogar die medien wenn von spiegel bis
zur welt ihr nahegelegt wird die
kanzlerkandidatur doch jemand anderes an
zu tragen
dann muss das dann auch so wird die
alarmzeichen für die grünen sein herr
wissing also wenn eine kanzlerkandidatin
die frage nicht beantworten kann
ob sie bereit ist sich von der
linkspartei zur kanzlerin wählen zu
lassen dann hilft es ja nichts dass man
eine inhalts show veranstaltet das sind
ja ganz wesentliche die menschen wissen
wollen insofern wird dieser parteitag
nichts ändern an der an der tatsache
dass die grünen ganz bunten sicht
wesentliche dinge die den wählerinnen
und wähler so werden sie diesen und
diesen trend im moment frau lührmann
noch nicht stoppen
also wenn ich es auch mal also passiert
gerade gemacht haben das ist so wie wenn
sie den trainer von fc bayern fragen ob
denn dortmund das bessere team ist das
genau deswegen kommt noch eine frage die
jetzt irgendwie hier uns nicht
weiterbringt also meiner meinung nach
das wird jetzt auch nicht überraschen
hat dieser parteitag annalena baerbock
starken rückenwind gegeben das
parteiprogramm zudem sehr viele
änderungsanträge gab es am ende einmütig
beschlossen war schloss beschlossen
worden
sie hat ein starkes ergebnis bekommen
für die nominierung und der phase des
wagens seien schnelle fragerunde einmal
mit ihnen gestartet der klingbeil die
sinn- und hieß ja wie teuer wird es nach
der wahl nach der wahl wird das leben
für millionen deutsche teurer ja oder
nein ich glaube dass klimaschutz uns
einiges abverlangen wird aber wenn sie
in zwei programm der spd rhein gucken
dann sagen wir 95 prozent der menschen
an steuerlich entlasten und das heißt es
wird für viele auch bestens leben
herr blume können sie eine garantie
geben für die union dass es keine
steuererhöhungen nach der wahl gibt ja
oder nein
[Musik]
ja denn wir wollen mit neuem schwung
starten aus der krise und neuen schwung
kann das land nicht nehmen mit mehr
belasten mit mehr verboten mit mehr
staat mit mehr steuern mit mehr schulden
das führt uns in die gegenteilige
richtung wir müssen tatsächlich auf
neues wachstum setzen dh war das eine
garantie keine steuerung nach der wahl
herr neubauer sagen sie ihren menschen
in augustusburg nach der wahl wird es
wahrscheinlich für euch teurer
ja sage ich und das ist ehrliche antwort
und der heutige abend sollte
aufgezeichnet werden wir das wird sich
zeigen dass ich recht behalte und das
ist doch komisch das problem ist nochmal
wir müssen mit den leuten reden wir
müssen das erklärt du bist eine klare
wege haben dann ist es auch gar nicht
das problem was du hier immer machen
dass wir versprechen irgendwas und nach
der wahl ist vor der wahl
und die quittung wird es geben und ich
kann immer noch vor augen dass wir so
weitermachen
wir wissen ganz schnelle fragerunde
machen wir kurz das anderes thema im
lebenslauf getrickst haben sie das schon
gemacht ja oder nein nein frau lührmann
herr laschet hat an seiner uni vor
vielen jahren als dozent man noten so
frei hand vergeben auch an studenten die
gar nicht in seinem kurs waren hat sich
die ausgedacht ist das eigentlich
schlimmer als im lebenslauf zu tricksen
ja oder nein herr weswegen herr
kemmerich es gerade zum fdp chef noch
mal gewählt worden in thüringen völlig
zu recht hat er sich das redlich
verdient ja oder nein das ist eine
entscheidung des landesverbandes
thüringen gewesen ich glaube meine
haltung die der bundes partei ist
hinreichend deutlich geworden also ich
hatte gar nicht gehört ja oder nein
redlich verdient ja oder nein das ist
eine entscheidung des landesverbandes
thüringen gewesen die so votiert haben
das ist das was mich daran festhalten
kann ja also ich finde es richtig
schlecht nein also und wollen sie aber
nicht sagen um den kollegen da nicht
rein zu fischen
ich will ihnen einen mann zeigen herr
blume das ist dieser herr und der sitzt
seit mittlerweile mehr als 100 tagen in
haft weil er keine gez gebühr zahlt
sitzt er da zu recht ja oder nein im
einzelfall kann ich jetzt verzichte ich
nicht beurteilen
der einzelfall ist dass er keine gez
gebühr gezahlt hat in
nordrhein-westfalen und deswegen in haft
ich bin ganz ehrlich ich würde davon zum
ersten mal ich kenne die umstände nicht
und deswegen muss ich einfach sorge ich
kann und mag es nicht wollte würden sie
vor allem an auf eine kanzlerin annalena
baerbock heute abend richtig wetten ja
oder nein
auf jeden fall klar ich will ihnen und
der runde ein letztes foto zeigen dass
stammt vom g7-treffen in großbritannien
und ist dieses hier hinter mir
sie sehen die kanzlerin angela merkel
mit ihrem ehemann joachim sauer
daneben boris johnson und seiner ehefrau
kerry und angela merkel & carry begrüßen
sich weiterhin mit dem ellenbogen obwohl
alle mittlerweile durchkämpfte boris
johnson war zudem auch selbst corona
krank das heißt da wurde sich auf
höchster ebene weiterhin so ein bisschen
albern finde ich mit dem ellenbogen
begrüßt verstehen sie das noch
hecklingen bei dass da immer noch so ein
theater eigentlich aufgeführt worden
sind darunter sich die sind dabei an der
frischen luft und wie gesagt alle
durchgekämpft und trotzdem noch so kann
man das nicht lassen
er weise da muss ich ihn deutlich
widersprechen das ist kein theater
sondern bundeskanzlerin ist vorbild da
gucken millionen menschen in und wir
sind noch lange nicht durch durch diese
pandemie es sind ganz viele menschen
noch nicht geimpft die sind noch nicht
auf der sicheren seite
es ist für alle anstrengend sich an
diese regeln zu halten es ist
anstrengend masken zu tragen das weiß
ich auch aber ich sage ihnen das ist
eine frage der solidarität dass wir
jetzt auf den letzten metern alle
solidarisch bleiben das heißt auch die
geimpften auch die genesenen und dazu
gehört ellbogen begrüßung maske tragen
und das schaffen wir jetzt als land auch
noch das heißt er blume für sie auch
noch keine zeit zur rückkehr zum
handschlag
naja also die einfache hygieneregeln die
sollten wir weiterhin hoch halten
denn fakt ist wir leben auch in den
deutschen großstädten in einigen
clustern dass die indische variante sich
beginnt deutlich auszubreiten und in
großbritannien sind die inzidenz trotz
seines großen nimmt fortschritt auch
über die 50 wieder gesprungen
bei corona darf man nicht alles jetzt
fahren lassen ich bin froh über alle
schritte zur normalität die wir erreicht
haben
und natürlich kann man manche fragen
noch diskutieren werden die auch auf den
tisch kommen in den nächsten tagen
stichwort masken pflichttermin
öffentlichen raum aber ich kann nur
davor warnen jetzt so zu tun als sei
corona schon vorbei wir haben's ein paar
mal erlebt dass wir uns zu früh bei
corona gefreut haben und das einst die
einfachsten mittel die aha regeln in
brüssel wieder machten pflicht ich halte
die für die geringste zumutung und einen
sehr guten schutz nach wie vor herr
blume hat gar die masken pflicht
angesprochen erklingen weil ihre
ministerin christine lambrecht die
justiz und die übergangsweise auch
familienministerin die sagt muss noch
mal überprüft werden jetzt die masten
pflicht weil sie eben auch eine
einschränkung für den alltag ist was
muss man da noch überprüfen und während
sie dafür die jetzt auslaufen zu lassen
ich hatte die woche jetzt eine ganz
spannende diskussion noch mit
schülerinnen und schülern als meinen
wahlkreis wo die masten pflicht liter
aufgehoben ist wieder und jahren gesagt
warum sollen wir die dinger nicht weiter
tragen sind doch noch gar nicht alle
geimpft und deswegen noch mal ich glaube
es verlangt uns als gesellschaft nicht
vieles ab wenn wir jetzt im öffentlichen
nahverkehr
dort wo wir wirklich auf menschen
treffen wenn wir dort die masken
weitertragen ich halte das für richtig
und glaube das ist jetzt ja eine
übersehbare zeit auch also wenn die
mutation nicht so krass wie the worst
case befürchten dann ist das doch jetzt
eine frage von wochen und die sollten
wir jetzt uns noch an diese regeln
halten und die macht wie lange muss ich
sagen noch eine frage von wochen sagen
sie gerade wie lange etwa das ist jetzt
das kann ich nicht bewerten weil wir in
der tat ja auch schon ein paar mal
gehofft hatten das ist jetzt vorbei es
liegt dann kam die mutation aber wir
sehen gerade den fortschritt wir sehen
gerade dass es vorangeht und insofern
würde ich heute stand heute sagen es ist
eine frage von wochen
das heißt sie so wie sie die antwort
aber begonnen haben mit ihrem beispiel
von der schule sie werden im moment
nicht dafür selbst in der schule wo es
gelockert wurde die maske abzulegen
sie werden daher vorsichtiger ich fand
es spannend dass die schülerinnen und
schüler mir aus eigenen stücken gesagt
hat warum sollen wir
machen wir wollen es weitermachen ich
finde das ist erstmal ein hohes zeichen
von solidarität dessen junge generation
hat die sagen wir gehen alle nach hause
wo unsere nicht geimpften eltern dann
sind und wir können die überträger auch
dieser dieses corona virus sein und das
fand ich ein bemerkenswertes zeichen und
werden die jungen leute das wollen dann
sollen sie doch weitermacht noch im
unterricht tragen können oder
erschreckend wie schnell man sich wie
schnell so was zur gewohnheit geworden
ist herr neubauer
die nehmen sie das wahr gibt es einen
großen druck in augustusburg oder haben
die menschen möglicherweise bei ihnen
die maske längst abgelegt überall auch
im privaten wie geht man damit der
masken pflicht um also bei uns ist ja
ärgerlich dass wir eins zusammen
hotelprojekte in deutschland hat das
funktioniert hat wissenschaftlich
bewiesen mit digitalen möglichkeiten und
gut tests verschieben sicherheit zu
schaffen wir hätten das gerne auch
schulen ausgeweitet da war auch die
akzeptanz da ist es vom bundes lockdown
pauschal mit weggebügelt worden wir
reden jetzt über masten wir sind nicht
vorbereitet wir sind digitalen weg nicht
weiter gegangen
virologen wangen uns vor dem nächsten
herbst ich fürchte wir werden dort
genauso häufig rein starten wie es die
letzten jahre war und wir sind noch
lange nicht durch da bin ich noch ganz
natürlich sicher und ich finde es sehr
schade dass wir dass wir diese führende
nation der dichter denker die industrie
nation schlechthin das nicht schaffen
vernünftige digitale systeme test system
ist so zu etablieren dass wir längst
schon viel sicherer sein könnten also
das ja das hat leider länger gedauert
als den impfstoff zu entwickeln
herr blume letztes wort nur um es noch
mal klar zu haben justizministerin sagt
massen pflicht überprüfen herr klingbeil
ist er deutlich vorsichtiger also
richtung massen pflicht auslaufen lassen
oder geht er ihn das zu weit aktuell
man muss bei corona immer alles und zwar
auch jeden eingriff auf den prüfstand
stellen und ich bin mir sicher auch die
masken pflicht über die wird noch einmal
zu sprechen sein aber alles zu seiner
zeit und mit einem kurs von vorsicht und
umsicht würde ich sagen sind wir durch
die korona krise insgesamt gut gekommen
besser jedenfalls gekommen als die
meisten anderen länder
in europa herzlichen dank für die
diskussion das war ein weiterflug am
ende bis zu masken pflegt aber ein
bisschen was können wir doch erfahren
können in unserer diskussion über wie
teuer könnte das werden nach der wahl
ist bleiben wir natürlich so ist es nach
60 minuten viele fragen offen die werden
wir in diesem wahlkampf weiter vertiefen
und mit ihnen immer wieder diskutieren
danke für diesen sonntag abend mit ihnen
wolle man erklingen bei herr neubauer
herr wissing und der blume herzlichen
dank und das waren die richtigen fragen
an diesem sonntagabend wir sehen uns
wieder nächste woche um viertel vor zehn
am abend
[Musik]